et à ce débat lpl continue place aux
matchs des idées confrontation de points
de vue ce soir entre françois kalfon et
isabelle veyrat masson va d'abord
s'arrêter sur le bobo de la sécurité
mises en place aujourd'hui par gérald
darmanin
il a fait suite aux polémiques autour
des violences policières présumées il
est censé permettre deux choses
essentiellement un renouer le lien entre
les forces de l'ordre et les français 2
écoutez les policiers et les gendarmes
pour comprendre ce qui ne va pas dans
leur formation ou sur le terrain les
échanges vont durer jusqu'au mois de mai
devront déboucher sur la construction de
la police de demain voit cela avec flora
sauvage coup d'envoi du beauvau de la
sécurité l'objectif de ce grand débat et
de poser les bases de la future loi de
programmation de la sécurité intérieure
lors de cette concertation
sept thèmes doivent être abordés la
formation des policiers
l'encadrement les moyens humains et
matériels la captation de vidéo au coeur
de la controverse sur la loi de sécurité
de l'eau balle la réforme de l'igpn
accusée de manquer d'indépendance et le
lien entre les forces de l'ordre et la
population
bien entendu la majorité de la
population française est plutôt
favorable à la police
néanmoins il ya quand même une fraction
autour de un quart à un tiers qui a pas
forcément une bonne image de nos de nos
forces de l'ordre parce que voilà il ya
eu des histoires de 2,1 de violences
policières le sort d'une chose est
claire a notamment été a eu de fortes
répercussions il ya eu tout le mouvement
des jeunes après les propos d' emmanuel
macron en décembre où il avait reconnu
des contrôles au faciès et des violences
de la part de certains policiers
alliance et l'unsa les deux principaux
syndicats chez les gardiens de la paix
avaient annoncé qu'ils ne
participeraient pas aux bobos de la
sécurité avant finalement de poser leurs
conditions vous pouvez pas faire un
débat sur la sécurité sans parler
d'abord des agressions à l'encontre des
policiers demandé des peines minimum et
surtout cet outil qui peut faire de la
transparence sur la politique pénale en
france
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est engagé à ce que le
thème de la relation avec l'autorité
judiciaire soit intégrée dans la
concertation ainsi que la question de la
gratuité des transports publics pour les
forces de l'ordre et le dispositif
relatif à la mutuelle
la crainte forcément c'est que ce soit
une main
un peu chorégraphié ou à la fin c'est ce
sont les revendications syndicales qui
l'emportent
la concertation débutera fin janvier et
doit durer quatre mois entre les
revendications des syndicats des forces
de l'ordre et les attentes des français
l' équilibre sera complexe à trouver est
avec nous pour le match des idées on
dirait que ce soir dans à lpl isabelle
veyrat masson bonsoir directrice de
recherche au cnrs vous dirigez le
rapport le laboratoire communication et
politique françois kalfon bienvenue vous
êtes conseiller régional d'île de france
membre du bureau national du parti
socialiste
ce bon vaut de la sécurité beaucoup
disent c'est un grand débat finalement
avec les forces de l'ordre et les
citoyens plutôt une bonne initiative
isabelle veyrat masson
écoutez on a tous a envie de sourire
devant les grenelles les bobolais
évidemment surtout que ségolène royal
n'est jamais loin pour nous faire rire
aussi
donc la première action maintenant quand
on essaye de regarder la chaux
sérieusement est-ce qu'il ya des chose
de plus important que d'essayer de
régler cette question des relations
entre l'as une société et sa police donc
la question la sécurité c'est ça
évidemment il faut introduire la justice
mais cette question des assisses de
sécurité le hante nos sociétés modernes
puisque finalement on part plus faire la
guerre on a les grands les grands
dangers j'allais dire avant les
épidémies maintenant on a d'autres
grands dangers m'enfin disparaissent un
peu et mais il ya cette question de la
du danger qui est au coin de la rue et
de la peur de la police air qu'il faut
pas que la police soit que ce soit soit
une offre un soin la groupe qui nous
fasse peur eu peur qu'elle ne nous
protège donc la question elle est
essentielle et puis là dessus on en
parlera j'imagine le terrorisme les
assassinats au coin de la rue la
violence policière pendant les
manifestations
la question des black blocks
l'inquisition bon y'a tellement de
questions que faire un beau me semble un
minimum quand est-ce que vous parlez de
la conscience ou du manque de confiance
des français dans leur police est vrai
qu'à quelques chiffres et j'en donne
juste quelques uns c'est le sondage et
la bhl tout dernier en décembre dernier
la confiance dans la police tombe à 60 %
c'est moins 9 points 6 mois - 16 points
par rapport à avril 19
il fallait bien faire quelque chose
alors j'ai un darmanin parle des sept
péchés capitaux moi j'en vois au moins
deux des péchés capitaux privatiser la
police républicaine à des fins de
maintien de l'ordre pendant deux ans et
demi on a eu finalement une police qui
n'a fait que du maintien de l'ordre pour
protéger un pouvoir aux abois
alors est la police fait son travail
dans les manifestations mais la police
ne peut pas régler une impopularité
persistante ou une incompréhension
totale entre le pouvoir exécutif et les
français est d'une certaine manière il
faudrait un bcg une sorte de rappel à de
deuxième vaccin pour monsieur macron
puisque vous avez vu il a récidivé nous
sommes 66 millions de procureurs on y
viendra ça sympa ça c'est pas le rôle de
la police est donc on a sécurisé la
police en faisant ça et la deuxième
chose me semble-t-il c'est si c'est un
bon ou de la sécurité avec les français
très bien si c'est le bout des syndicats
de police avec un gérald darmanin
affaibli qui en est l'hôte âge c'est un
problème
or je constate que avant même que les
syndicats de police participent à ce
fameux beauvau de la sécurité ils ont
obtenu quitter la revendication
catégorielle c'est à des remboursements
de trajet très bien pour eux entre
finalement le commissariat de police et
leur domicile qui invite y est un péché
capital hausse est de monsieur darmanin
qui consiste à finalement avoir une
sorte de de hotline avec les décisions
des magistrats quand les personnes sont
placées
je pense que la sécurité mérite mieux si
on je pense que c'est une occasion
manquée parce qu'effectivement les mots
volés grenelle les ségur
c'est la quintessence chez emmanuel
macron du et en même temps c'est à dire
que le lundi il s'affiche avec alliance
police nationale darmanin le mardi il
donne sa compassion pour les victimes
des violences policières ce que ce dont
on a besoin c'est d'un cap d'une colonne
vertébrale et j'ai envie de dire ça mais
ça a existé par le passé quand vous
prenez des grands ministères intérieur
j'en cite deux ou trois qu'on a bien
connu qu'il s'agisse de pierre joxe qui
s'habille cheese de jean pierre
chevènement
vous aviez à la fois de l'humanité du
coeur d'un côté et du dialogue entre la
police et habitants de l'autre
sans mener en moi transiger quoi que ce
soit sur la fermeté je pourrais ajouter
monsieur cazenove qui était un très bon
niveau intérieur l'est d'ataq absolument
excessive gt r on ne peut pas à la fois
de reprocher à quelqu'un d'être dans le
dialogue de vouloir un chef qui décide
et que ses appuis après on va lui
reprocher au contraire peut-être un
jupiter et de décider d'une manière trop
unilatérale et de matériaux non je suis
déçu de faux dit tout donc il est comme
tout résident la république depuis que
depuis je ne sais pas et le premier
grenelle je sais pas d'où ce que je
pense de sa date mais qui essaye
d'essayer de régler les questions
démocratiquement en réunissant les
partenaires
je ne vois même pas comment on peut
critiquer ça c'est pas du en même temps
ça s'appelle la démocratie et on ne
réclame de plus en plus on trouve
qu'elle n'a pas assez
et maintenant on va carrément choisir
les gens au hasard il faut que tout le
monde soit là
bien évidemment il faut pas que ce soit
des du faux-semblant il faut que les
vrais alors que souvent on a le
sentiment comme avec une commission que
ces graines elles servent à déplacer la
question à régler on l'a bien vu pour le
grand débat il a servi à un moment donné
simplement arrêter les manifestations
des jets régionaux
c'est vrai on peut mais sur le fond
comment peut-on chrétiens aux alliances
que vous cachez spécialiste de la
communication comme nous sommes dans une
chaîne parlementaire c'est le jeu
démocratique democratic l'hermine ma
phrase avant de faire je ne sais quel
grenelle ou espèce de grand barnum et
une opposition elle peut noter les
points qui sont positifs et elle peut
aussi vous voyez mal comment on peut
faire ça ça veut dire l'état nos débats
démocratiques
elle peut émettre des doutes quant à
l'efficacité des mesures prises et bien
moi je dis je redis ici que monsieur
macron dès le lundi aux victimes des
violences policières qu'elles ont raison
et le mardi aux forces de l'ordre
quels doivent être confortées et bien
puisque vous êtes spécialiste de
communication comme les messages sont
parfaitement confus
personne n'y comprend rien et ça se
termine comme ça s'est terminé sur la
convention citoyenne sert qu'à la fois
en 10 c'est le grand moment le grand
moment tom de la démocratie directe et
on s'assoit sur un tiers voisin cas
françois kalfon la vérité n'est pas
binaire faut être vous savez vous savez
comme disait jeu et il faut hélas 0 cra
si elle est faite de différents
habitudes différentes ça gora et à
l'assemblée nationale il y a les
syndicats il y aller il ya la rue il y a
aussi des beauvau et d'égrener ce que je
constate sans doute vous avez raison
mais moi si tu sais quand l'été vous
avez prononcé le mot de jupiter les
jeunes de nos jours avec leur langage
d'hier est un jupiter en carton parce
qu'en réalité ils naviguent à la godille
en fonction des crises qui sont devant
lui
ce dont on a besoin c'est de rétablir et
ça avait été fait en son temps par
lionel jospin de réserve et de servir
une confiance non pas dans la super
structure là haut
le jour où les trois jours d'un beauvau
mais dans les soubassements de la
société la confiance entre la population
et ses forces de police et cette
confiance et ça paie on va avancer un
petit peu je voudrais qu'on revienne
maintenant sur cette critique de jean
castex qui a pris tout le monde de court
c'est le deuxième thème de ce match des
idées lors de son déplacement en alsace
il visité le siège de la nouvelle
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui
fusionne depuis le 1er janvier le haut
rhin et le bas le premier ministre s'est
posé en ardent défenseur des identités
locales ça c'est une chose mais ce qui a
le plus surpris c'est sa forte remise en
question de la réforme territoriale
menée sous françois hollande tient tient
au côté je n'ai jamais été convaincu par
la création de ces immenses région dans
certaines ne répondent à aucune
légitimité historique
[Applaudissements]
et surtout ne me paraissent pas répondre
aux besoins grandissants de nos
concitoyens pour une action publique de
proximité
il n'en fallait pas plus pour re motiver
les farouches opposants à cette carte
régionale à l'image de frédéric bierry
président ait l'air de la nouvelle
collectivité européenne d'alsace il
était interrogé ce matin sur public
sénat et côté bien évidemment nous on
l'appelle jouons notre voeu le
démembrement de la région quand tu es tu
sais nous pourrions reconstituer une
halte à philo lui nous l'avons fait
institutionnellement avec la
collectivité européenne d'alsace
suffirait de transe de transférer toutes
les compétences de la région et on
aurait une une collectivité d'un nouveau
genre mais qui ferait beaucoup plus
visible et plus efficace pour nos
concitoyens
isabelle veyrat masson et vous a surpris
cette sortie de jean castex il ouvre la
boîte de pandore
oui non non il est dans le rôle qu'on
lui a depuis le départ affectés sur
l'homme des régions l'homme du local
l'homme des pouvoirs les plus près des
gens extérieurs ce qui m'a frappé en
entendant ça c'est à quel point et c'est
un problème pour nos démocraties tous
les toutes les questions deviennent un
peu comme sa lointaine déphasé à côté de
ce que nous sommes en train de vivre
tous au même moment c'est dire la
question de la pandémie c'est un vrai
problème pour le politique et il essaye
on voit bien de se dégager de cette
pandémie de ces problèmes sanitaires
avec qui un problème un fait divers une
autre fois en prendre deux sociétés et
là évidemment l'homme des régions va
parler de région et va ressortir une
d'une querelle en oeuvre on peut être
sûr sur ces sujets là ça c'est vous
c'est comme à l'école on sort on lance
la querelle de la lecture globale ou de
la lecture à fabriquer tout le monde et
tout le monde part très rapidement et on
va essayer des querelles qui me semble
un peu secondaire
même si bien sûr chacun vit
ces questions régionales ce qu'est ce
qu'on vient 6 mais pas sur roulettes sur
ce qu'ils on a repris l'alsace et la
lorraine
donc non bien sûr il ya des guerres sur
ces sujets là mais c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment et parc jean castex
ça paraît un peu alors pour le coup de
la com et sur le fond françois kalfon
une critique très sérieusement la
réforme de françois hollande
bon après il faut prendre un peu de
distance est ce que l'ensemble des
régions il y en avait beaucoup sur le
territoire il avait bien formaté je
pense que non c'est une évolution était
possible et même souhaitable
est ce que toutes les régions
aujourd'hui son et clients et la réponse
est non très clairement et la région
grand thèse puisque jean castex en parle
elle va aux confins de la seine et marne
jusqu'à l'allemagne 1 c'était quand vous
quittez la cdma vous êtes dans la région
grand est
jusqu'à l'allemagne maintenant heureux
si tu en es recontextualise ans les
propos de monsieur castex il parle
devant la communauté
finalement le l'espèce de collectivités
d'alsace que les alsaciens ont créé si
on demandait à cette collectivité
d'alsace ils veulent même figuré avec la
lorraine ce qui ferait du sens est-ce
qu'ils auraient envie d'intégrer les
lorrains je n'en suis pas sûr que ce
soit très clair enfin pardon mais encore
une fois avec le maquereau nisme c'est
toujours la même chose il est
commentateur de la vie politique ou
détecteur le premier ministre on ne sait
plus parce que si nous annonce qu'il
veut finalement amon pas un an du
scrutin
c'est ce que vous avez dit est ce que
c'est on opportunité c'est le moment
modifier ces régions pourquoi pas enfin
jerry pu y aura un chantier c'est parce
qu'il fait c'est parce qu'il fait là on
a bien compris
donc c'est une analyse de remarques pour
se trouver sympathique devant son
auditoire est effectivement là où je
vous suis est ce que c'est bien le
moment
alors nous sommes ici dans la chaîne des
territoires puisque public sénat lui ai
donc c'est un débat vraiment intéressant
mais finalement j'ai envie de dire tout
ça pour ça est un commentateur et que ça
vous parlez du coc vis de la crise qu
vide qui a aussi mis le doigt sur un
problème d'un pouvoir trop centralisée
d'un procès d'état qui a pas mentionné
proximité entre les autorités et les
habitants là il nous dit en fait il nous
aurait fallu des régions à taille
humaine où où il faudrait que la beetle
la population soit plus proche des
autorités et là c'est grande région
éloignée la population oui alors là le
débat sur le pouvoir local voire
national pouvoir régional qui suit
l'actualité ces événements il ne l'est
pas l'aide la manière dont il l'a prise
oui c'est ça que je voulais dire et sur
lequel vous nous faites faisait réagir
mais on voit bien que la question elle
est toute la complexité de ce choix
entre les jacobins et les girondins
historiettes est repartie elle n'a pas
été réglé parce que il y est on a vu les
avantages les inconvénients du jeu du
centralisme très français on a vu un
inconnu puisqu'on a eu le sentiment
qu'on ne laissait pas les gens régler la
question localement d'introduire de la
delà de la différence et la souplesse sa
souplesse et on a vu également
rappelez-vous marseille
comment sur la localement en fonction
des petits besoins locaux on a oublié
l'intérêt national
l'intérêt l'intérêt même régionales
parce que quelque part face à la
pandémie
on a tous le même intérêt vous savez le
problème que vous n'avez pansements vous
allez l'avoir parce que vous allez avoir
une messe où un rassemblement qui va
apporter la pandémie donc tout cela et
est apparue avec le problème grave de
parfois du localisme
on a vu la même chose en allemagne on a
dix ont formé des allemands ils ont des
régions génial et puis finalement ils
ont les mêmes problèmes que nous donc
que la discussion soit là elle et elle
est importante elle me semble très
important que même encore là aussi on
est morte pour ça mais elle est
difficile est retranché alors vous avez
posé à juste raison au delà de la
remarque jean castex la question de
l'articulation des territoires de l'état
du coc vide il ya deux niveaux me
semble-t-il d'abord le premier niveau
csp s'est finalement les grands
territoires qui ont failli moi je pense
plutôt quelle que soit l'orientation
politique des régions qu'elles ont été
très aidé entre et notamment
souvenez-vous de la période des masques
ou si les régions et départements le
grillage
je veux dire mois et la deuxième chose
vous le savez vous recevez des élus tous
les jours ici sur ce plateau même pour
déployer la campagne de vaccination ce
sont les territoires qui ont sauvé
l'état l'état disait lui-même quand il
en était derrière mme edith stein on
aura 300 de maquis destination en
réalité les préfets ont convoqué des
mers et c'est les maires qui ont peu
permis de passer en 1971 vaccin dernier
point les gens du dernier point là où il
ya une question institutionnelle
intéressante pour moi y compris sud
culture jacobine
c'est ce qui a pas à faire muter face à
la déroute de l'état dans certains
domaines et dans la santé ce une déroute
les ars est un échec profond est-ce qui
a pas faire muter un certain nombre de
compétences dans les régions vers une
forme de fédéralisme en allemagne il ya
des succès et il ya des échecs mais il
ya un ministre de la santé dans chaque
länder
il ya un ministre de l'économie dans
chaque länder et ce qui change un peu la
donne pour moi c'est qu'on peut pas être
dans cette posture de l'état ni
responsable ni coupable
si vous avez demain la région grand est
sous la région ile-de-france qui loupe
sa campagne de vaccination il ya des
élections régionales ensuite les
personnes sont sanctionnés
là le haut fonctionnaire de la rs
personnes d'abord connaît son nom
et comme vous le voyez que directeur
général de la santé il n'est pas
sanctionné
eh bien il est bien que les uns et les
autres puissent être sanctionnés mais
par sur les échecs des uns et des zones
et parfois l'anonymat protège aussi
quand vous disiez pas sanctionner ça
aussi ça la force de la delà de la
bureaucratie quand c'est négatif ou
l'administration comment elle n'est pas
c'est à dire qu'on peut décider sans
avoir la pression de son éditeur donc c
c'est compliqué de décider entre
justement le fait de se présenter au sco
au jugement des uns et les autres en
ayant un visage annonce est une sanction
est au contraire de pouvoir décider dans
l'intérêt général sans être sans subir
des pressions troisième thème de ce
match avec vous ce soir l'enfant
utilisation supposée des france est une
critique est en train d'émerger
sérieusement depuis quelques semaines la
multiplication des interdits des
consignes et des conseils notamment dans
cette crise qu'ovide commence à
interroger sérieusement mathieu laine
prof à sciences po et proche des manuels
macron publier un livre sur le sujet
infantilisation c'était la nounou qui
vous veut du bien c'est le titre il a
présenté sa théorie dans plusieurs
interviews dans celle ci dans le jdd
qu'on nous explique comment fêter noël
est sidérant ce que les politiques et la
haute administration aurait pu éviter
c'est de nous parler comme à des enfants
des incapables
cette novlangue de soignants les papiers
les mamies réduit le citoyen un élève du
primaire auquel un maître ferait
sempiternel mans la leçon pour son bien
alors les papiers les mamies pour rappel
c'était ça peut aller chez papi et mamie
à noël on ne mange pas avec eux on coupe
la bûche de noël en deux papiers même y
mange dans la cuisine et nous sommes en
jeu dans le dans la salle à manger
alors pour en parler on accueille dans
ce match christophe belser bonsoir vous
êtes porte-parole du think tank
génération libre qui a lancé en mars
dernier l'observatoire des libertés
confiné vous avez l'impression qu'on est
infantilisé depuis le début de cette
crise bonsoir
alors oui je crois qu'on est
particulièrement infantiliser en france
je crois que cette la gestion de cette
pandémie révèle des réflexes politiques
profonds et en france on s'est retrouvés
notamment avoir cette attestation
obligatoire cette auto attestation à
remplir qu'on a vu presque nulle part
ailleurs
sinon je crois notamment en roumanie
pendant le premier confinement mais
surtout de la même démesure skis et ski
et ce qui est gênant c'est ce ton est ce
qu'on voyait dans le sujet quand on a un
premier ministre qui nous
l'iscid comme un bon père de famille
parce qu'on s'est bien tenu pendant les
fêtes c'est c'est un peu ridicule et
surtout je pense que ça affaiblit la
confiance dans les élus politiques et
qui est fait aujourd'hui un vrai
problème et surtout si on se compare je
sais pas à l'allemagne par exemple on a
une grande différence entre les discours
de macron finalement assez le
moralisateur et paternaliste et des
discours beaucoup plus technique précis
informatif d'une angela merkel et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les français ils
ont d'abord besoin d'information y
compris que les hommes politiques leur
disent qu'ils ne savent pas ou qu'il
leur dise je sais pas qui peuvent pas
vacciner vite et beaucoup parce qu'il ya
pas suffisamment de doses je pense qu'on
est suffisamment grand pour comprendre
et et je pense que c'est cette
accumulation de norme aujourd'hui fait
que beaucoup sont en train chercher à
louvoyer où beaucoup mahmoudi le le
danger sanitaire qui est là et je crois
que me plutôt que sur cet autoritarisme
il faudrait probablement miser sur
davantage d'autonomie
vous seriez convaincu vous que les
français mettre le masque dans les
transports si ce n'était pas obligatoire
et s'il n'y avait pas une sanction ou
une amende
hellmuth et je ne sais pas mais on peut
on peut voir ce que ça donnait pourquoi
pas c'est à dire on peut renverser la
charge de la preuve on est encore en
train de partir du principe que le
français ce ne ne respecterait pas a
priori de lui-même les règles
vous savez parfois où l'être humain oui
mais moi je vois le soir aujourd'hui
s'il s'est parfois je le rends à 21h je
vais très très peu de gens dans les rues
et je pense que les français peuvent
très bien comprendre ce qu'ils doivent
faire pour eux mêmes pour leur santé
pour la santé de leurs proches
on va faire réagir en plateau à ce que
vous dites et n'hésitez pas à nous faire
signe si vous souhaitez intervenir de
nouveau isabelle veyrat masson vous
diriez dans ce gouvernement a tendance
ce gouvernement en particulier parce que
c'est ce qu'il nous dit la tendance à
nous infantiliser
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
infantiliser s'il faut utiliser ça veut
dire donner des conseils précis on par
la main pour des jambons comme moi
j'entends ce jeune homme très savant qui
comprend tout à ce qu'on lui dit et qui
trouvait à moi je il a de la chance
moi je trouve ça extraordinaire mans
compliqué je trouve incroyablement
compliqué quand j'entends sur vos
chaînes d'information monsieur raoult ce
qui est chose et puis même à madame
lacombe guider autrement et c'est de se
trouver de décider j'en discutais avec
monsieur qui m'a accompagné jusqu ici
il m'a dit moi j'y comprends rien on
nous dit une chose dont nous dit
autrement c'est extrêmement compliqué et
les gens effectivement est le moins
fantaisiste est insupportable et quand
on entend l'écho de papier des mamies on
a tous été malades
on est d'accord mais bon c'est chaud pas
sûr que ce monsieur soit le gouvernement
professeur en revanche nous avons besoin
dans une situation compliquée dans
laquelle même la science la science même
les scientifiques ont du mal à se
repérer mois moi je suis aussi au cnrs
je discute avec eux tous les jours et on
a un groupe dans lequel on trie on
travaille sur ces choses là et on voit
bien qu'à l'inter de notre groupe il ya
des choses des gens qui disent des
choses différentes on a besoin que le
politique donne des repères
donne des indications mais le festival
de l'infantilisation peut-être c'est une
manière de voir les choses mais imagine
une société dans laquelle on nous disait
allez faites comme vous voulez démerdez
vous écouter les scientifiques vous
prenez vos décisions
rappelez vous que les gens puissent 75
ans et ce sont mes amis
ce sont des collègues sont tous en train
d'écrire sur facebook mais qu'on nous
laisse tranquille et si on a envie nous
est malade et de mourir
on s'en fiche ccdh outre enquête ce
n'est pas vrai ils n'ont pas envie de
mourir et devrait surtout se dire non
seulement nous allons encombrer les
hôpitaux mais ensuite nous allons
contaminé nous nos enfants nos voisins
et c'est donc ce n'est pas vrai que la
liberté totale est possible dans ce
grand alors françois kalfon et je vous
redonne la parole évidemment un
christophe zehler coûtait déjà je pense
qu'il faut être précis
est ce qu'il ya une femme a vite senti
lisation la réponse est évidemment oui
est-ce que c'est simplement les
politiques qui sont évidemment le
punching ball idéal qui pratiquent
l'infantilisation moi je pense qu'il ya
aussi on a vu apparaître d'ailleurs
beaucoup le sont oui tout est compliqué
une sorte de de parole des autorités
sanitaires et médicales ou bien souvent
les plus inventives is en sont les
grands professeurs de médecine
d'ailleurs certains ne sont pas du tout
dans le domaine de l'épidémiologie je
vois des néphrologues nous donner des
conseils des rhumatologues toutes sortes
de gens message est rare et qui donnait
des conseils y compris l'académie de
médecine qui eux sont infimes utilisant
quand vous dites sans finalement sans
aucune précaution
un peu comme les grands mandarins le
faisait encore 25 ans pour annoncer un
cancer aujourd'hui merci les choses ont
évolué à bâle il faut pas parler il faut
pas téléphoner en les transposant le
métro donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
est bon et qu'est ce qui est mal vécue
par les français d'abord que quand vous
regardez ce peuple dont on nous explique
aux plus hauts sommets monsieur macron
le fait que nous sommes 66 millions de
râleurs de gaulois procure à chaque fois
une nouvelle version c'est comme les
nouvelles nées saison sur netflix et le
même thème mais ça recommence là aussi
mais c'est surtout que c'est faux c'est
faux les français ont été incroyablement
disciplinés et il n'y avait pas besoin
de les prendre pour des enfants pour le
faire ces terres que globalement les
consignes sont respectées que vous
regardez ce qui s'est passé
sur la période des fêtes qui n'a pas été
idéale dans des tas de pays ça a
correspondu au bond et épidémiques
ils se sont testés jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y
ait plus de tests ils ont épargné les
personnes âgées autant qu'il pouvait le
faire
donc à un moment donné nous on n'a pas à
passer le bac d'ailleurs que maintenant
au contrôle continu tête grâce à chaque
fois donc c'est ça le sujet est hélas
deux dernière chose qui est très
importante c'est que face à cela on a un
état extrêmement défaillant ces terres
que vous avez eu la question j'y reviens
pas des masques déteste maintenant du
déploiement de la vaccination qui est
fait grâce aux collectivités locales et
vous passer la frontière vous allez
madame merkel qui ne s'en tient pas
simplement au vaccin mais qui va
chercher elle-même les anticorps
monoclonaux
là bas au canada qui va chercher
d'autres traitements alternatifs c'est à
dire c'est ce qu'a dit le l'intervenante
générations libres et pourtant on est
noir sur le champ politique c'est à dire
que les hommes politiques se comportent
dans d'autres pays pas dans tous pas au
brésil par exemple mais se comporte
parfois comme des techniciens qui ceux
qui ont une feuille de route pour régler
un problème très sérieusement lanières
une forme d'égalité entre le peuple
souverain et des lianes et des
finalement des responsables politiques
qui agissent au responsable et bien en
france nous avons cette infantilisation
doublé d'incompétence au plus haut
sommet de l'état zèle terre oui je bats
je rejoins je rejoins totalement ce
qu'est ce qui vient d'être dit je suis
un peu étonnée qu'on ait des personnes
qui sèche pour d'autres ce qu'elles
doivent faire comme si elle était mieux
que ces personnes donc pourtant a priori
ce serait irresponsable c'est quand même
un paradoxe
moi je crois que le rôle du gouvernement
c'est d'abord d'expliquer ce qu'il sait
la situation y compris ce qu'il ne sait
pas d'informer je pense qu'on est quand
même si on est dans une démocratie c'est
pas pour rien s'est il faut aussi pour
que chacun puisse exercer son autonomie
donc
donc est ce que je peux pour prendre un
autre exemple je vous parlais tout à
l'heure des amendes dans les transports
mais là c'est la ceinture de sécurité
elle a été imposée parce que les
français avaient tendance à ne pas la
mettre
elle a été imposée sous peine d'amendé
aujourd'hui tout le monde la meille
personnes plus personne ne se pose la
question
nous sommes passés par une phase
d'infantilisation mais qui était
peut-être nécessaire pour notre vie oui
ou non on peut savourer énormément de
débat mais mais la responsabilité de
chacun de prendre un risque de lui
revenir
non non non non c'est ce que je disais
sur les gens de 75 ans ça ne marche pas
comme ça avec eux c'est à dire que vous
tuer des gens quand vous quand vous ne
portez pas non c'est à dire que vous
entendrez les hôpitaux et du coup il y
aura le cancéreux du coin la femme qui
va accoucher qui va être
particulièrement mal ce n'est pas vrai
on n'est pas une personne en dehors de
la société
nous sommes des êtres sociaux et chaque
rôle de chacun c'est de faire en
conscience et en fonction des las de ce
que le lui dit la société et du ried de
prendre un certain nombre de risques
pour les autres aussi que mais c'est
particulièrement vrai pour en
l'occurrence c'est sensuel et sexy la
ceinture de sécurité n'est que
partiellement exacts pardon non parce
qu'elle a les idées c'est pas un bon
exemple
parce qu'effectivement jeu qu'on veut
vous tuer vous tuer tout ce que je peux
et s'est développé ma pensée dans
l'exemple la salle ans mais très
rapidement les 1 de la ceinture de
sécurité il ya bien une coercition qui a
permis une évolution du comportement une
protection finalement or quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe sur le peu vide
on a maintenant un an de recul
celui qui est défaillant et celui qui
pose la sanction celui qui est
défaillant c'est l'état 1 c'est l'état
qui n'a pas été en capacité par les
stocks de masques
au début de cette crise de protéger donc
il ya des vies qui ont été finalement
retirés par une inconséquence de l'état
et ceux qui sont plutôt vertueux ce sont
les citoyens et je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'important je rajouterais
même un point c'est que les
responsabilités politiques c'est quand
vous avez un responsable un haut
fonctionnaire ou un ministre qui commet
une erreur lourde
ça a été pointé par une commission
denquête au sénat
je parle de monsieur salomon qui a menti
sur les masques s'était dit ça a été
relevé par une commission d enquête
parlementaire et qui est toujours en
responsabilité ce monsieur est il fondé
à nous donner des coercition alors que
globalement nous nous faisons notre
travail de citoyen vous voyez l'autorité
en soit c'est une question importante
mais l'autorité finalement imposée par
des gens qui ont failli ça pose une
difficulté supplémentaire coercition les
coercition sont beaucoup plus lourdes à
l'étranger - ma meilleure amie habite au
canada
et quand il sort si l'on 1500 euros
damende je crois qu'il ya 10000 euros
damende quand vous allez à l'étranger
pour venait gr la coercition elle n'est
pas française n'était pas méchante et à
qui en veut à tout le monde qui veut les
faire taire et tuer tout le monde
ensuite les punir pour les punis et
c'est la fin de ce match merci beaucoup
dit avoir participé merci christophe
belser d'avoir été avec nous dans ce
match des idées fin de cette émission se
retrouvent demain 18h et à 22h30 dans un
instant auditions publiques l'invité ce
soir olivier dussopt pts ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
demain bonjour chez vous un invité
fabien roussel secrétaire nationale du
parti communiste excellente soirée
[Musique]
pour voir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
on se retrouve tous les mercredis après
midi pour une grande session
d'information parlementaire à 14h on
revient sur le fait politique du jour et
l'actualité du sénat avait que des
parlementaires des commentateurs et des
duplex à 15h ne manquez pas les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement en
intégralité et en exclusivité sur notre
antenne une heure d'échangés directs
entre les sénateurs et le gouvernement
fit à 16 heures c'est l'heure du débrief
on débrief tout ce qui s'est passé dans
cette enceinte
alors rendez vous tous les mercredis à
14 heures sur public sénat